what is it about President Trump that
you love so much
well to be honest I just started
dreaming about him I am you know I have
a prophetic gift and the Lord started
speaking to me about him totally not
just conversations with the Lord she's a
prophet and in my one dream I actually
choose because I'm totally not political
I'm a minister I travel around the world
you haven't
had mid-shine your light and don't hide
it
all and had an encounter with no you
were I I don't see it but what I loved
about this is that I actually in one of
my dreams I sat in front of President
Trump and I knew he was giving me some
type of job you know I was kind of like
and I said to I'm the Lord in my dream I
said I don't want to lose my Ministry
for this like all right so anyway as
we've talked about before mental illness
not a joke very sad need to increase
access to mental health treatment in the
United States let's leave it there with
the South African Maga preacher but that
is what this is where we are right now
as far as the Trump movement and it is a
really scary and sad thing